at Fiumicino Airport in Rome they're
taking no chances
for good reason the people being
monitored with heat scanners have just
flown in from Wuhan the center of the
outbreak they left before the Chinese
city was put in lockdown
but scenes like this have played out
around the world at Sydney Airport
serving Australia's largest city many of
those flying in from Wuhan on Thursday
wore face masks they knew they'd be
screened but there were no reports of
illness and they weren't overly worried
before we got off the plane and a few
Australian government people come to
spray spray everywhere and when we get
off and some people you're in the u.s.
one person's known to have contracted
the virus health officials in the state
of Washington where the man lives say
he's well and should be allowed home
soon as of now there are at least 16
identified close contacts local health
department's started reaching out to
them yesterday and continue to do so
today and the list of countries with
confirmed cases of the virus is getting
larger most in eastern Asia but some
further afield the data that we've
gathered has suggested you know that
this could be a very dangerous virus but
potential for global spread and even I
don't think it's being too extreme to
say even potential you know for a global
epidemic but I don't think that's
inevitable at this point and I and the
next couple of weeks will be really
important to making an assessment of
what the real risk is still the mere
possibility needs checks like this at
major airports until medical experts
know a lot more there's a whole series
of questions we have to ask we don't
have all of those answers yet we have
some of them we know how to diagnose it
we increasingly know how to treat people
when they get it what we don't yet know
is when somebody's infectious and who
they pass it on to somebody else the
next few weeks could tell us exactly how
much of a threat this coronavirus poses
worldwide
Nadine Barber al-jazeera